[Música]
hola bienvenidos a migrante es el
programa semanal de france 24 sobre el
éxodo
[Música]
por su estratégica ubicación panamá es
un país de tránsito pero además de
acogida para cientos de migrantes por
allí pasan incluso africanos y asiáticos
que buscan continuar su viaje hacia el
norte pero también se quedan algunos
centroamericanos que quieren una vida
lejos de sus países es por eso que hoy
revisaremos dos situaciones que se
agudizan en el país por el kobe 19 uno
de los más perjudicados por la pandemia
son los migrantes que quedan atrapados
sin poder continuar su periplo en medio
de comunidades pobres y también
afectadas por el virus en las que crece
en ocasiones la xenofobia como país de
tránsito y antes de la pandemia los
migrantes pasaban en promedio una semana
en las estaciones migratorias panameñas
pero desde que centroamérica cerró sus
fronteras por el virus se ven obligados
a quedarse hasta que se autoriza la
reapertura de los pasos entre los países
veamos a continuación lo que pasa en la
peñita zona del darién en la frontera
entre panamá y colombia
después de cruzar una de las selvas más
intransitables del mundo estos migrantes
quedaron varados en la peñita un pequeño
poblado indígena en la selva del darién
el hacinamiento en que viven la falta de
comida y el cierre de fronteras por el
kobe 19 que bloquea su tránsito los
llevaron a protestar pero los hechos
terminaron en violencia y los locales
los acusan de quemar campamentos de
organizaciones de ayuda hechos que ellos
niegan
máxima la policía quema el hospital ahí
con gas cuando sus pistola con balas
ellos dice que los inmigrantes que quema
al hospital pero si hay justicia ello
tiene que ver si fuera inmigrante que
quema el hospital o la policía porque
los inmigrantes no tiene pistola acá no
tiene gas para tirar
ahora son al menos mil 500 migrantes
deambulando por estas calles entre
ciudadanos de haití jugo bangladesh
nepal congo camerún e indica la tensa
situación en la zona aviva sentimientos
xenófobos prende la casa entonces como
como panameño pedimos ayuda a las
instituciones que oigan el grito de
auxilio de puerto peñita necesitamos que
nosotros que se unan y nos ayuden o lo
sacan o lo sacamos porque ya no
aguantamos otra palabra que tuviéramos
el questra aviar porque decir la palabra
verdaderamente estamos secuestrados
porque nosotros no podemos salir a
trabajar no podemos dormir bien porque
con una piedrita que cae el techo
nosotros también alerta llamas pero por
el cierre de las fronteras los migrantes
tendrán que continuar aquí por un tiempo
más y para evitar nuevos actos violentos
el gobierno anunció deportaciones
lógicamente por el tiempo que han pasado
en panamá esa fase de de miedo hacia el
cob y ahora se ha transformado
en una fase de impaciencia pero ellos
tienen que entender la situación que
está pasando porque no podemos afectar a
terceros y mucho menos violar las leyes
de panamá y las normas sanitarias que
tenemos actualmente en el país por lo
menos 280 migrantes absolutamente
involucrados en los hechos en la peñita
serían deportados según el servicio
nacional de migración de panamá en 2019
unos 24 mil migrantes cruzaron la selva
del darién desde colombia este año 4000
transitaron por la peligrosa ruta
y como lo decíamos al comienzo de este
programa panamá además de un país de
tránsito sirve de acogida para otros
cientos que emigran este es el caso de
un grupo de nicaragüenses que ahora
busca retornar a su país tras la crisis
causada por el coronavirus nicaragua es
la quinta nacionalidad con más permisos
de residencia otorgados por panamá
después de haber construido una nueva
vida en panamá douglas un chef
nicaragüense quedó desempleado sin más
opciones empacó lo que pudo y ahora
espera un bus en la terminal de ciudad
de panamá que lo lleve de vuelta a su
país
vendí todo lo que me dio tenía aquí para
vivir
y resultó de que ahora
por eso cree que retornar es la solución
más viable ante la crisis ocasionada por
el coronavirus
y aprenderme pero no hay como le llama
aquí este cuarentena la agencia na por
ahí está minando cuidándose por si truco
[Música]
como él muchos de sus compatriotas
exigen que les permitan regresar pero el
cierre de las fronteras bloquea su
tránsito
muriendo de hambre del corona veremos de
hambre entonces necesitamos salir de acá
que no se opongan porque necesitamos
podemos obtener lo que quiera en nuestro
país con nuestra familia que la urgencia
de los migrantes radica en que algunos
se practicaron la prueba de kobe 19 un
requisito que les pide nicaragua para el
reingreso pero esta prueba sólo tiene
una vigencia para el país de 72 horas el
pasado 2 de agosto cerca de 200
nicaragüense lograron ingresar a su país
después de dos semanas varados en la
frontera con costa rica
en los últimos días los nicaragüenses
varados en panamá recibieron el permiso
de movilización para retornar hacia su
país por grupos y el dato de migración
de la semana la llegada de migrantes
sanitarias se disparó en casi un 150 por
ciento durante el último año desde
agosto de 2019 hasta julio de 2020 21
mil 618 personas llegaron a las costas
italianas según datos del ministerio de
interior
el organismo sin embargo destaca que las
cifras son mucho menores a las
registradas en los últimos años
[Música]
hasta que inmigrantes de france 24
gracias por acompañarnos en esta nueva
misión los invitamos a comentar en
nuestras redes sociales con el hashtag
migrantes f24 siga conectados con más
información en france 24 y france 24
puntocom
[Música]